BEFORE IT'S TOO LATE.
AND THAT'S THE ANGLE.
>> ALL RIGHT, JOINING ME NOW IS
GORDAN CHANG, GAIN STONE
INSTITUTE SENIOR FELLOW AND
AUTHOR OF THE GREAT CHINA TECH
WAR.
GORDON WITHIN THE LAST HOUR OR
SO WE LEARNED THAT PELOSI
VISITED PARLIAMENT AND DID MEET
WITH THE TAIWANEES PRESIDENT WE
HAVEN'T SEEN A RESPONSE FROM
CHINA YET BUT WILL THEY RAMP UP
THE THREAT AND WILL THOSE
THREATS TURN INTO REAL ACTION?
>> CHINA HAS TO DO SOMETHING
LAURA BECAUSE THEY MADE THIS A
TEST OF WILLS AND IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR SPEAKER PELOSI TO
GO AND ACTUALLY BE PHOTOGRAPHED.
THAT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
YOU KNOW, THE NEW YORK TIMES
SAY, OH, THIS IS JUST SYMBOLIC.
WELL, FOR PEOPLE IN AN INSECURE
TOW TARNISM STATE IT'S
EVERYTHING.
WHAT SPEAKER PELOSI SAID TO
PEOPLE IN TAIWAN PEOPLE IN THE
WORLD PEOPLE IN AMERICA IS THAT
WE WILL NOT BE INTIMIDATED.
THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE IF SHE
DIDN'T GO WE WOULD HAVE BEEN
EMBOLDENING THE WORST ELEMENTS
OF THE CHINESE POLITICAL SYSTEM
BY SHOWING THAT INTIMIDATION OF
AMERICA WORKS.
THIS IS A GREAT DAY FOR AMERICA.
>> Laura: NOW THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, GORDON, IT KEEPS
DISTANCING ITSELF FROM PELOSI.
HERE WAS JOHN KIRBY TODAY.
>> WHEN THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
SAYS WE STAND WITH TAIWAN,
AMERICA STANDS WITH TAIWAN, HOW
CAN THE CHINESE CONSTRUE THAT AS
ANYTHING ELSE BUT THAT YOU'RE
SPORTING ITS INDEPENDENCE?
>> I'LL LET THE SPEAKER SPEAK
FOR HERSELF.
WE DO NOT SUPPORT TAIWAN
INDEPENDENCE, AND NOTHING HAS
CHANGED.
>> Laura: NOW, GORDON, WHAT DOES
THAT RESPONSE MEAN FOR FOLKS OUT
THERE WATCHING WHO DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE NUANCES OF THIS
RELATIONSHIP.
>> YEAH, THAT RESPONSE IS
BASICALLY COMMUNIST PARTY
TALKING POINTS.
KIRBY ACTUALLY SAYING WHAT
BEIJING WANTS HIM TO SAY.
AND, YOU KNOW, BIDEN HAS MADE
THIS PROBLEM WORSE.
HE STARTED DOING THAT ON
JULY 20TH WHEN HE SAID TO
REPORTERS, OH, THE PENTAGON
DOESN'T THINK THAT THE SPEAKER'S
TRIP IS A GOOD IDEA.
BECAUSE WHAT HE WAS SAYING TO
BEIJING WAS, LOOK, OUR
ADMINISTRATION IS DIVIDED.
COME IN AND INTIMIDATE US SOME
MORE AND THAT IS, IN FACT, WHAT
HAPPENED LAURA BECAUSE THE
ALREADY DIRE SOUNDING THREATS
BECAME EVEN MORE DIRE AFTER
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S COMMENTS.
THIS BECAME A REAL TEST OFLESS,
BECAUSE BIDEN WOULDN'T SUPPORT
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> Laura: NOW, GORDON, SOME OF
MY GOOD FRIENDS DISAGREE WITH MY
ANALYSIS, YOUR ANALYSIS OF THE
SITUATION.
I THINK THIS IS AN INVALUABLE
IMPORTANT MOMENT FOR THE UNITED
STATES.
BECAUSE THE ESTABLISHMENT CAN'T
HIDE ANYMORE.
THEY CAN'T KIND OF PAPER THIS
OVER.
THEY'RE LITERALLY THREATENING,
IN NOT SO MANY WORDS, TO SHOOT
HER PLANE OUT OF THE SKY.
AND THEY'RE LIKE, OH, LET'S DO
MORE BUSINESS WITH CHINA, LET'S
DROP THE TARIFFS ON CHINA.
LET'S ENRICH CHINA.
WHAT THE HECK HAS THAT STRATEGY
GOTTEN US OVER THE LAST 20
YEARS?
>> IT'S GOTTEN US INTO A VERY
DANGEROUS SITUATION WHERE THERE
ARE NO GOOD OPTIONS.
ON THURSDAY, WHEN XI JINPING
THREATENED BIDEN, BASICALLY
THREATENED THE LIFE OF THE
PRESIDENT BY SAYING THAT THOSE
WHO WOULD PLAY WITH FIRE WILL
PERFECT I SHALL.
YOU KNOW, BIDEN SHOULD HAVE HUNG
UP THE PHONE.
INSTEAD, WE GET LANGUAGE FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE READOUT ABOUT
THE NECESSITY OF THE DEEPENING
COMMUNICATION TO WORK WITH CHINA
IN AREAS WHERE WE AGREE.
YOU KNOW, CHINA LOOKS AT THAT
AND SAYS, WE OWN THE OVAL
OFFICE.
SO THIS IS A TIME WHERE THE
UNITED STATES NEEDS TO STAND
TOGETHER AND WE NEED A PRESIDENT
WHO IS WILLING TO DEFEND THE
UNITED STATES INSTEAD OF JUST
PROPEL GATING COMMUNIST PARTY
TALKING